quand le proviseur s'avance des listes
de noms à la main ça sent
l'aboutissement de l'enseignement
secondaire pour la plupart des élèves de
terminale un moment ont forcément
émouvant et pour tout le monde c'est
toujours un vrai plaisir
parce que c'est le moment où on partage
avec les élèves des années passées au
lycée les résultats du bac sur panneau
d'affichage avec l'attente de
l'ouverture des grilles entre copains
copines de terminale à l'ancienne ça se
fait encore ça permet de se fabriquer de
vrais souvenirs parce que cette ambiance
là personne ne la retrouve devant son
écran sur Internet
[Musique]
bonjour on a l'impression que vous avez
eu votre bac non oui je l'ai eu
attendais pas du tout et vraiment son
bac avec mention ça donne du ressort
il n'y a pas que les élèves qui ont
cette récompense pour les profs c'est un
peu la même chose et tous les ans en
tant qu'enseignant c'est aussi une
satisfaction
tes résultats de voir à quoi on a pu
contribuer dans leur vie je dirais de
lycéens puis leur futur vide étudiants
c'est grâce à eux qu'on a eu le bac
elle est émue oui mais deux enfants
viennent d'avoir le bac aussi donc c'est
vrai que les avoir en classe moi je me
suis aussi retrouvé un petit peu voilà
c'était mes autres enfants et il y en
aura d'autres cela vont maintenant se
diriger vers les études supérieures avec
à coup sûr bien rangé dans leur mémoire
le souvenir de ce jour-là